it is vitally important that your
password not be
the same across different platforms
because when
platforms get compromised the usernames
and passwords sometimes get dumped and
passed around among hackers hi my name
is eva galperin i work for the
electronic frontier foundation where i
am the director of
cyber security and i'm here to debunk
some myths about cybersecurity
the government is watching me through my
camera
it is possible to remotely trigger
somebody's camera if
you install a remote access tool on
their device
that is something that hackers do that
is something that criminals do
that's something that governments do but
in order for the government
to install the software that they need
to do in order to track you through your
camera
they need a warrant from a judge it is
more likely that you will be watched by
hackers
or if you're a student by your school
than it is that you're going to be
watched by the government
since it is possible for someone to turn
on your camera without the little green
light going on
if you would like to make sure that when
that happens they don't see anything
then it is recommended to put a sticker
over your camera most people aren't
targeted
with this stuff and usually you don't
have to worry what i recommend that
people do
is that they download antivirus software
from
pretty much any antivirus company and
just run a scan
on the highest setting the dark web is a
scary place full of illegal activity
the dark web is a network of
websites that you have to use
something like tor browser or any of the
other you know sort of
guaranteed to be anonymous browsing uh
applications in order to get to and it
can be any kind of website this is not
necessarily
just used for you know selling drugs and
trading child porn for example facebook
has a dark website they have dot onion
site that you can only get to
if you are logged in using tor tor and
other applications like it are not just
used by
criminals the other people who
frequently need anonymity online
journalists activists people who are
talking to journalists
and of course people in authoritarian
countries who are very worried about
their government spying on their social
media use
tor browser originally funded by the us
navy the government needed
a way for people to be able to go to
websites and maintain their anonymity
and not have
their digital footprint seen by the
people who are running the websites
privacy is dead if privacy was dead
governments and law enforcement wouldn't
have to keep trying to kill it
by proposing new laws and talking about
all of the stuff they can't possibly get
into but most
importantly privacy is not about
living as a hermit on a mountain by
yourself never communicating with
anybody
privacy is power over your information
understanding what kind of trail you
leave
behind enables you to limit that trail
or enables you to limit who can see that
trail the kind of security and privacy
advice that you give to people
really varies person by person but there
are a couple of things that
are that are good for everybody like
eating your broccoli and taking your
vitamins
you should have long strong
and unique passwords for all of your
accounts and you turn on the highest
level of two-factor authentication
you're comfortable using take your
software updates
this is how you benefit from the work of
the security team
and finally that you actually sit down
and you think about your threat model
you think about what you want to protect
and who you want to protect it from
google reads all my gmail google
actually does read all of your gmail
google is storing all of your email if
you
are using a gmail account they automate
scripts which read the contents of your
mail and who you're you're mailing back
and forth to
what they do not do is
read your email and then tell the
government what's in it google
has extremely strict privacy
rules internally and if a government or
law enforcement wants to get their hands
on this data they have to show up
with a subpoena for the metadata or
a warrant for the actual contents of
your email but there is a difference
between
protecting your data from hackers
protecting your data from advertisers
from governments and law enforcement a
strong password protects you from
hackers
this is partially correct and that a
strong password
is one of the things that you need in
order to secure your account
it is vitally important that your
password not be
the same across different platforms
because when
platforms get compromised the usernames
and passwords sometimes get dumped
and passed around among hackers and
hackers will do what we call
credential stuffing where they try to
get into your account
using these old passwords from other
platforms
you should also be very careful about
your security questions your security
questions
are usually things about you that a
person who knows you relatively well
knows a person who knows you well might
know the name of the street that you
grew up on
or the name of your favorite teacher or
your favorite breed of dog
and so instead of answering those
questions truthfully
i recommend answering them as if they
are simply more passwords so now you
have a different
long strong unique password for every
account
and trying to remember them all is a
pain and this is why i recommend using a
password manager
which you install on each of your
devices and will
generate new passwords for you that way
you can make sure that you never forget
your password as long as you remember
the single password to your password
manager so how often should people
change their passwords
sometimes programs or companies will
require you to change your password
every 30 days or every 90 days
this is actually not helpful at all it
turns out that
users create shorter and more memorable
passwords when they have to change them
all the time
that they don't change them very much
and therefore you're not actually
getting a big gain in security
your best bet is what we call diceware
where you use
somewhere between five or six randomly
generated or randomly chosen words
that way you get a very long very
difficult to crack
password that is also fairly easy to
remember
encryption will keep my data safe
encryption is scrambling the data or the
metadata so that it is not possible for
somebody who sees it
to read the information that you are
sending encryption
is used in two very different ways
on the internet one is called encryption
and transit
encrypting data in transit is if you
look
at your browser and you see the url at
the top of your browser
you see that it probably starts with the
letters https
the s at the end there stands for
security it means that the
information which is being sent between
you and the website that you're going to
is encrypted so that anybody else was
sitting on the network
somebody else in your coffee shop the it
manager
at your office whoever it is that runs
the network
at your school all of those people can
only see that you are going to the
website and they can't see specifically
what page you're going to and they can't
see what it is that you're doing there
for example they can't see what pictures
you're downloading or they can't see
what password you're entering the other
kind of encryption
is end-to-end encryption when you
encrypt something in transit you are
trusting
the person who runs the website but no
one else
and when you are doing end-to-end
encryption
you don't even have to trust the person
who runs the website the only person
that you're trusting
is the person that you are messaging and
that is because you have the an
encryption key and
uh the person that you're sending a
message to has an encryption key
and that is how these things get locked
down the good news
is that there's a lot of powerful
encryption that's being used
to protect you every day and you don't
even know it whatsapp for example has
more than a billion users all over the
world and their messages are end-to-end
encrypted but what's most important
is to understand where your data is
going who has access to it
and what they would have to do in order
to access it if you do not want them to
public wi-fi is safe
back before the majority of the web was
encrypted using https it was
extremely easy for anybody who is
sitting on the same network as you
including somebody sitting on the same
public wi-fi as you
sitting in a cafe with you to not only
see everything that uh that you were
browsing and everything that you were
typing in
but also to inject false information
into that stream so that you would
say type your password into a website
that the hacker controls and now the
hacker has your password and they can
log into your stuff
it used to be extremely unsafe i
and it was really common for hackers to
hang out on public wi-fi
this is less true now that the web is
mostly encrypted
a lot of people recommend using vpns vpn
stands for virtual private
network it is just a way of creating
a tunnel between you and wherever your
vpn is
in order to protect your browsing or
your internet activity from whoever is
running the network that you're on for
example
if you are in a hotel and you use hotel
wi-fi
and you log in to work using your vpn
the hotel can only see that you logged
into the vpn they can't see
what your traffic looks like but work
can see all of your traffic and so you
need to be able to trust them
cyber attacks are the new warfare
most of what we think of as cyber
warfare is actually cyber espionage
and in the cases where there is cyber
warfare
that's extremely rare probably the most
famous example of that
is stuxnet when the us and israel
worked together on a piece of software
which
broke the centrifuges that the iranian
government was using
in order to refine radioactive materials
for their nuclear weapons program
but really it almost never happens what
is important
is that uh governments are not the only
threat actors out there for the most
part if you are an ordinary person
you are more likely to be targeted by
criminals
by hackers who want your money a lot of
what people think of
as hacking is actually security research
people who are
trying to break systems for the better
in order to
inform both users and the people who
make the systems about these
vulnerabilities before bad people take
advantage of them
the hacker mentality can be applied to
anything hacking
is is not about being a bad person it
is about understanding systems and
subverting them
understanding the limits of surveillance
and of hacking is really important in
order to build out a
place for yourself where you can feel
safe and where you can understand where
your information is going and who has
access to it